all right well in the meantime john  gruden could be fine for not wearing a  mask on the sidelines both gruden  and saints head coach sean payton they  were seen many times with their masks  off  gruden later apologized and revealed for  the first time  he did battle the coronavirus during the  off-season gordon said if he does get  fined he will not fight it  and the nfl already leveled some hefty  fines against three coaches  and teams for not wearing a mask during  games on sunday the head coaches of san  francisco  denver and seattle each have to pay a  hundred thousand dollars  the teams will pay a quarter of a  million players are not required to wear  face coverings on the field but the  coaches are